hello everyone and welcome to this
session of blockchain
my name is Sora and I'm part of the
Sylvian team so let's get started so
what's in it for you today we are here
to understand the concepts of why do we
need blockchain what is Bitcoin and
blockchain how does blockchain work
concepts around blockchain like sha 256
encryption public and private key
distributed public ledger concept the
proof of work and mine then we will also
look at different applications of
blockchain in different industries who
uses blockchain and a demo now why we
need blockchain imagine there are two
entities a and B living far away and
want to transfer money to each other one
is in America and one is in Asia as of
today in order to transfer the money
they rely on a third party on which they
have to trust now what are the possible
results by doing this way any
transaction there are high transaction
fees associated with it there could be
problem of double spending they could be
internet based frauds and poor data
recovered now let's see what does all
these means high transaction fee for any
transaction bank will charge a
relatively very high amount of
transaction fee as compared to what as
of today cryptocurrency charges double
spending double spending is a digital
error where money can be spent twice
from your account so for example if you
have $800 in your account and you might
end up spending thousand dollars which
is an invalid transaction hackers might
attack financial institutions and gain
unauthorized access to steal your money
poor data recovery retrieving loss data
is very difficult in a centralized
system as there is only a single copy of
information but as compared to the
distributed databases the distributed
ledger technology like blockchain it is
easy as the information is distributed
across multiple nodes now these problems
can be solved using Bitcoin and
blockchain technology and we will see
how so let's first understand what is
Bitcoin and blockchain bitcoin bitcoin
is a digital currency we
is used to send and receive money across
the world it is a barrier-free currency
in a decentralized manner with minimum
transfer fee or we can say it's gonna be
relatively very very less as compared to
what bank charges it doesn't involve a
third party no intermediate reason
involved thereby reducing the cost of
transaction fast and cheap transfer is
possible personal information identity
of a user is hidden and all the
transactions are cryptographically
secure as they are being signed using
your private Bitcoin does this by
storing and transacting the money over a
distributed peer-to-peer network called
blockchain so therefore it becomes very
important for us in order to understand
if how Bitcoin works we also need to
understand what is blockchain because
that is the underlying technology so
what is blockchain blockchain is a
distributed database of immutable
records called blocks which are secured
using cryptography now here we can see
once the data is recorded it cannot be
changed
it cannot be altered and that is the
attribute of immutability of blockchain
a block is a record book which contains
the details of transactional data every
block is given an aggregated set of
transactions to be validated verified
and added to itself so basically a block
consists of four primary details which
we will take a look at it contains the
hash of a previous block it contains an
aggregated list of transactions it also
contains the value of nonce and the hash
for the block itself which itself is
like a digital signature of the block so
hash of previous block it holds the hash
value of the previous block to which it
is connected contains details of several
transactions which are aggregated in
this block nonce nonce is a random
number a random value which is generated
to derive a hash value which should be
less than the target decided for the
block and hash is alpha numeric value
which is used to identify the
itself and it is Union now let's deep
dive into blockchain blockchain creates
a chain of blocks as we can see here in
a blockchain the previous hash value of
a block is always equal to the hash
value of its previous block as we can
see here the previous hash value of
block number two is 23 a which is the
hash value of block 1 also the previous
hash value of block 1 is 0 because it is
the first block in the blockchain and it
is called the Genesis block so the first
block is called the Genesis block and
does not have any previous hash value so
consider an example now where a person
tries to tamper the block block number 2
then he will try to change the hash of
block number 2 will change there by the
previous hash value of block number 3
now does not stand valid now the hash
value of block 2 and block 3 does not
match which will make the following
blocks the blocks ahead of block number
2 invalid now this particular feature of
blockchain helps us eliminate data
tampering now let's see how does
blockchain work Jack wants to send money
to Elsa the requested transaction of
Jack wanting to send money to Elsa will
be sent to all the peer nodes on the
network of computers now the transaction
sent to loads is verified by a set of
people of a typical set of nodes called
miners
once verified the transaction is
combined with other transactions to
create a new block in the blockchain and
as a result the receiving party Elsa
receives the amount in blockchain a
transaction could be for a
cryptocurrency for data or any kind of
asset so the transaction can be for any
digital asset which holds value on the
network now let's take a look at what
are the typical features of blockchain
these are typical features of blockchain
it involves sha-256 algorithm based
encryption proof of work consensus
algorithm usage of public
and private key in order to sign the
messages on the network the role of
minors in order to validate and verify
the transactions and how to create a now
a distributed public ledger now what is
sha-256 encryption for a transaction
block chain uses cryptographic keys to
secure identities and hash function to
make the blockchain unalterable so
cryptographic keys includes two kind of
keys private and public key and it uses
a hash function which includes sha-256
now as such a 256 stands for the number
of bit it takes up in memory secure
hashing algorithm no hash function takes
an input data and always return an
alphanumeric output of 64 characters
which is 256 bits so as you can see over
here if you field any data like we are
here feeding an example of welcome to
simply learn the hashing function will
return you 256 bit value and now that
hash value is unique the value returned
by a hash function is called hash value
it is impossible to decode the original
message using the hash value itself so
hash value does not discloses the
original message in the hash function a
minor change in the input data will
result in a different hash value and
that is the unique feature of the
hashing function you make a small change
and the hashing value will change all
together completely
now sha-256 is a one-way function you
give an input pass it through the
hashing function you get the output but
the reverse is not possible so in simple
terms decrypting back the original text
is not possible using sha 256 which
makes it very very secure now
cryptography uses public and private
trees to encrypt and decrypt data but a
private key is always kept secret with
the user so if I have to send a message
to someone I will sign it with my
private key which is secret to me but I
will share my public key in order for
users to decrypt the message and
validate that yes the
sender of the message is me so in the
blockchain network public key can be
shared with all the Bitcoin users in
order to do the transaction so let's
take a look what is that the entire
verification process so when you
initiate a transaction it is passed
through a hashing function which in our
case is sha-256 the output is passed
through a signature algorithm with the
user's private key again and then we
receive a digitally signed document so
that hashing output plus my private key
is used to generate a digitally sign
document which is then floated on the
network with my public key then the
encrypted output is distributed to the
Bitcoin network using the public key so
the digitally signed document and the
public key is used by the miners to
verify the transaction and once that is
done they include the transaction on the
block and the transaction is then Mazdas
completely so what is distributed public
ledger a blockchain is a distributed
ledger in which the digital data is
recorded and verified by each node for
preventing tempering of data so if you
can see over here we have a network of
nodes
among these knows few might be the
miners who are taking the responsibility
of verifying and validating the
transactions on each block and in lieu
of that verification they will be
rewarded so we will see when you're
really talking about mine so let's take
an example over here jack is sending ten
BTC su l Elsa now which is verified by
John in the network John is the miner
now once the transaction is verified by
John the result is being broadcasted is
transferred to other nodes as a result
the block becomes valid and gets added
to the blockchain and once it is
transferred to other nodes the ledger of
each nodes record this transaction and
all the ledgers now have the same
information on the network who note only
a valid transaction is propagated across
the Bitcoin users while if any invalid
transaction is identified it is
discarded at the first node itself which
received it now
if any user tries to tamper the data
every user in the blockchain maintains a
copy of the ledger as I said once the
transactions are verified they are
distributed across the nodes all the
Ledger's are updated now if someone goes
back in the blockchain and tries to
tamper the data in one of the blocks the
other nodes will be able to identify the
invalid block and will discard it so if
anyone tries to modify the data the
alternate transaction copies with other
users will negate the alteration now
let's take a look at of the proof of
work algorithm proof of work is a
consensus algorithm which is used in the
Bitcoin network it is the process to
determine a number called as nonce along
with the cryptographic hashing algorithm
to produce a hash value lower than the
predefined
target for the block so if you see over
here the miners main task is to identify
the nonce which is the random number in
order to generate the hash value which
is less than the target now generally
the target is something like the hash
value should have leading zeros like
here in the example we can see it is
having leading zeros of two leading
zeros so in order to generate a hash
value with leading zeros like 2 or 3 it
takes huge amount of computing power for
the - to determine that so in order to
determine the nonce the miners need to
try about 20 points 6 quadrillion norms
values to get a 1 valid hash now how it
works
transaction data is distributed across
the users of Bitcoin network miners will
validate the unverified transactions add
them to the block that is their task to
do so miners compete to solve a
difficult mathematical puzzle which is
the generation of the nonce value based
on cryptographic hashing function and
this whole process is known as proof of
work the first miner who solves the
puzzle gets rewarded and this is the
purpose for which the miner has made the
investment in the hardware in the
computing power the energy which the
mining machine is consuming in order to
get the reward
once the minor has verified the block it
is added to the blockchain now let's
take a look at the process using the
sha-256 you generate a hash value use
nonce as an input to the hashing
function if the hash value is less than
the target know then you modify the
nonce value you repeat this activity if
it is less than the target value yes
then you are deemed to get the reward
your puzzle is solved node in the
Bitcoin network the target is adjusted
every 2016 blocks so as I mentioned the
target of having leading three zeros or
having leading four zeros that is
revised after every to zero once it's
blocked on an average a block is mined
every ten minutes
the difficulty of the puzzle is
maintained in such a way that it never
deviates too much from the average time
taken to mine a block now candidate
block proof-of-work so let's consider an
example where a miner
jack is competing to validate the block
number thousand now while Jack was
mining clock number thousand he was also
listening for new transactions so in the
transaction pool the transaction are
stored
they are basically parked until they get
verified and gets included in a new
block now unfortunately before Jack
could mine thousand someone else minded
and earn the reward now block thousand
has a valid proof of work now it is a
verified block so now Jack will start
constructing a candidate block which
will be known the subsequent block
sequential thousand won by gathering the
unverified transaction now from the
transaction pool so jack has now started
creating a candidate block pulling the
transactions from the transaction pool
into block number thousand one the
current block now is the candidate block
because it has not been validated and
does not have any proof of work yet this
block 1001 it's validated once any minor
succeeds in solving the proof of work it
could be Jack or it could be again
someone else
completing mining in blockchain when the
transaction contained a considered
confirmed a new block is added to the
existing blockchain and the bitcoins
concerned in the
action now can be spent now as of today
the miner who solves a puzzle
gets a reward of 12.5 bitcoins the
amount of Bitcoin rewarded for each
block added to the blockchain is half
for every 2 lakh 10000 blocks which is
approximately every 4 year so this is
called the huffing concept of Bitcoin so
approximately whenever the Fourier
threshold will be reached the reward
will get reduced to six point two five
bitcoins now let's take a look of
applications of blockchain in different
industries voting blockchain is a is a
very trustworthy mechanism which has
increased transparency in the voting
process supply chain uses the attributes
of blockchain of provenance and
traceability to detect to identify and
trace the supply of any asset from its
point of origin to its final destination
and if in due course any defect is
detected it can easily identify where in
the journey of the asset the defect was
generated insurance has a huge adoption
they are utilizing blockchain for
eliminating forgery and preventing false
claims as all the records and
transactions will be maintained in
blockchain immutable ledger it will be
very difficult for anyone to apply for
any false claims so as an example if the
health records are there on blockchain
the insurance companies can easily
validate the health claims made by any
patient through the blockchain digital
records accounting it virtually
maintains a record of accurate financial
information all the financial
transactions if maintained on an
immutable ledger can easily be validated
and verified and makes accounting simple
now who uses blockchain there are
organizations across the globe who are
adopting and have started using
blockchain example Walmart due to block
chains decentralized system the company
is able to protect its data from hacking
and it alteration British Airways with
blockchain flight data from various
sources are merged together and help
passengers receive accurate information
mask with blockchain the companies
able to provide an efficient transparent
and secure service in global trade
brilliant earth in order to track and
trace the provenance of high-value
gemstones they are using blockchain now
let's take a look at a demo let's go
over to some concepts which we have just
learned now here I want to demonstrate a
usage of the hashing function so as we
had learned the hashing function is a
256 big hashing function as such a 256
you can type in any data and it will
always generate a 256 bit hash and it's
going to be unique it's a one-way
function so it is not possible that you
will be able to derive the data from the
hash value and if I type the same data
it will generate the same hash value so
the hash value for blank is the same and
if I type anything it will always
generate the same hash value for the
same data set
now let's see how can we use the hashing
function in our block now here we have a
block which has its attributes which is
the block number a nonce value and like
this similar hashing function we have
the data set and hash value now the
difficulty level the target is already
set for the hashing function to have
four leading zeros so whenever I will be
mining the job of the miner here is to
generate a hash which should have four
leading zeros in the hash value and it
will use it will guess the nonce value
in order to generate such a hash which
is having four leading zeros so suppose
if I type a data set now the hash which
is right now you're seeing on the screen
is not mine and it does not have the
leading zeros the four leading zeros so
when I will click mine the nonce value
will change the miner has to guess the
nonce value to get the hash which is
having four leading zeros
here it is so the nonce which is
generated now which is fifty-seven
thousand four hundred and eighty it
takes huge amount of time processing
power so it would have gone a pretty
high value but it was able to guess it
at a decent amount of time now as soon
as I change the value again the block
has turned pink which means it is not
verified the hash has to be generated
now we will see the same concept we will
have multiple blocks in our blockchain
now here we have multiple blocks but we
have a new extra attribute called
previous hash so if you notice the
blocks right now currently have all the
previous values of the hash which are of
their previous blocks block number two
has the previous hash value of four
zeroes 1 5 which is the hash value of
its previous block and this is how a
typical blockchain is constructed now
there are a few things to be noted here
suppose I modify the data in the last
block so if you see the block hash now
needs to be changed because the data has
changed its hash has to be regenerated
so the previous hash value is the same
which was the hash value of the previous
block now the new hash has been
generated for this block which starts
with four leading zeros another thing to
be noted is suppose I go back in the
sequence and modify the data of any of
the previous blocks so all the blocks
ahead of this block number three now
have to be verified again because the
signature of block number three has
changed therefore the values of the
previous hash have to be updated for
block number four and five so when I
will mine block number three it has now
generated a hash value which is as per
the target block number four also has to
be mine and block number five also has
to be mined now this way we have created
our valid block chain so this
demonstrates if someone in a regular
block chain a minute block chain which
has high number of block chains blocks
so if they go and tamper any block in
the past all the subsequent blocks ahead
of that block have to be mined again
which will take huge huge amount of time
and processing power which makes it
impossible now we will see the
concept when we'll take this concept of
distributed now here we have a
distributed ledger we have three peers
PR aprv PRC all have the same copy of
the ledgers
now suppose there is someone who has
modified the data on PRA and generated a
block updated the block but the hash
value of block in PRA for block number 5
is different for what is of block number
5 at where p p lb which is the for x 0
fo and PA see also has the same hash
signature from as p RB so easily the
participants in the distributed network
will able to be identify that someone
has modified block number 5 at P array
which is not a valid block and it can
get disregarded know whatever example I
have been showing this has all been
random data we can take a look at the
typical transaction which actually
happens on a Bitcoin network now rather
than sending random data we can see here
the exact examples of the transactions
the transfer of money which actually
happens from one account to another so
this is a very good way to see that
these are the ways typically the
transactions are aggregated and mined in
a block and we can see in a typical
fashion all the three peers have the
same set of information on the
distributed ledger now if I modify any
of the transaction the block will get
invalidated and it would have to be
remind so what are the key takeaways
today for us we have understood why we
need blockchain what is Bitcoin and
blockchain how does blockchain network
work the features of blockchain and
applications of blockchain I hope you
had a great learning session and I'll
meet you next time in my next session
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here